déjà là on voit claude enfin quand on
parle de clos depuis le début de
l'émission là en l'occurrence et sur les
épreuves il est très fort et c'est alors
oui ça on peut pas lui enlever c'est
comme quand on dit il faut séparer
l'artiste de l'humain et ben là c'est un
peu pareil on enlève l'on sépare le
performeur de l'humain c'est un petit
peu ça donc toutes ces images sur les
performances de claude ok stop claude
c'est un champion très fort en épreuve
ça ok on l'enlève à côté de ça il ya
l'humain il ya la personne qu'il est et
ouest est un manipulateur c'est un fin
stratège
en effet c'est c'est quelqu'un qui peut
être arrogant et lors de ma saison il a
été mon l'a pas forcément vu donc on a
vu le clos de l'iss le cloud très forts
etc et mais en 2010 2011 enfin moi je
regardais pas à cette époque là mais il
était déjà comme ça donc en fait je
comprends pas pourquoi aujourd'hui les
gens sont étonnés de sa variété comment
il a toujours été comme en bas comme ces
manipulateurs arrogant dira que
factuelles bas bien sûr il m'a rabaisser
déjà en tant que femme ça soit
physiquement sur mon corps à me dire
mais n'était pas sportif toi mais je
comprends pas mais attends mais là c'est
tout mais non mais il ya des blagues il
ya rabaisser la femme en tant que tel
devant tout le monde et rigoler et même
lorsque j'étais plus dans le jeu ça
rigolait encore sur sur sa sur le corps
sur machin c'est un film ça c'était pas
filmer mais tu crois que ça prenait va
le montrer par non à peut-être qu'après
on sait que non on sait que la propre
peut-être dès fois que un peu montré des
choses qui qui sont dérangeantes au 6
mai mais de la deûle à être aussi aussi
je pense aussi macho et aussi je sais
pas c'est pas l'image de claude que
j'aime c'est pas c'est pas tout l'image
qu'on a de claude après en tant que
candidat c'est vrai qu'on peut être
victime d'un d'un d'un leader comme ça
mais je peux comprendre aussi l'attitude
de charlotte et son et sa frustration au
match super frustrés du tout de mon
aventure c'était simplement je raconte
ce que j'ai vécu
mon expérience avec claude mais comme
j'ai eu ça et comme à des moments on
rigolait énormément ensemble mais voilà
une personne n'est pas que comme ça
n'est pas que manipulatrice que
arrogante c'est un tout mais en effet il
l'est et sapho faut le dire que c'est
vrai il est comme ça alors enfin revenir
sur cherchons un instant mais guillaume
bas quand on voit les images prouvent
qu'on a l'impression que claude il a
pris la grosse tête et en fait ce tarif
chez les candidats de koh lanta c'est
une très bonne idée pour l'audience les
chances pas que ce soit une bonne idée
pour les candidats parce que vous avez
des gens normaux qui ont une vie normale
on l'a dit claudie des chaussures de m
qui du jour au lendemain se retrouve
avec une énorme exposition médiatique
vous avez quand même 6 7 millions de
personnes qui vous regardent chaque
semaine sur plusieurs saisons et qui
viennent aussi beaucoup d'argent ils
sont pas beaucoup payé sur koh lanta
mais claude c'est devenu une star il
travaillait beaucoup de marques donc
notoriété plus argens et les ingrédients
idéaux pour pété les plombs et je pense
qu'on dirait en tout cas on garde un
avantage qu'il a pris la grosse tête
gagner très bien fallu avant moi j'ai la
gagne encore plus d'argent la wii avec
les marques oui on va leur pas du tout
d'accord avec toi guillaume parce qu'en
fait là on le voit effectivement il est
peut-être un peu pète sec un peu
arrogant encore une face à un
spécialiste il est experte ça c'est
grâce à lui qu'ils gagnent l'épreuve les
jaunes et qui donc ils ont l'épreuve de
confort donne des conseils et donc il
donne des conseils et de la même manière
qu il explique comment on fait des
noeuds parce que les autres sont
incapables sont gardées on est donc
c'est normal que ce soit un leader et on
attend sa nuit tu vois c'est dans le
radeau il l'a fait deux fois il l'a fait
dans ma saison et avant donc
moi j'ai entendu malgré tout qu'elle
était et ça je rejoins un petit peu ce
que ce que vous disiez charlotte qu'il
était quand même un tout petit peu dans
le storytelling en tout cas à ranger et
chouchouté par la prod et il ferait et
c'est là où peut-être qu'il un peu
manipulateur des pactes avant le
tournage avec certains candidats comme
par exemple avec le moment où avec ses
moins de chansons mais là c'est le
casting avait soumis à tous les coups
oui claude aurait fait son casting à
tous ses copains donc forcément c'est
ennuyant même à gagner ce que j'essaie
déjà alors par rapport à cette saison là
ce qui se passe c'est que claude il est
trés mis en avant le voit énormément
c'est normal c'est un grand champion
c'est le plus grand champion et ce qui
s'est passé c'est que la production a
été un peu déçu de certains autres
candidats notamment comme sam qui est
très absent alors que sur l'édition
précédente où il était on le voyait tout
le temps donc du coup on voit énormément
que l'autre parce que c'est le seul qui
a vraiment joué le jeu et maintenant si
vous voulez bien je peux répondre à
charlotte church a sonné alors charlotte
je suis pas étonné par votre témoignage
je vais essayer d'expliquer où les
spectateurs ce qui se passe
vous faites partie d'un clan de quelques
personnes de quelques anciens de
candidats de koh lanta qui en veulent
énormément énormément à claude ils sont
armés mentalement par pascal vous êtes
très proche de pascal je pense même qu
avant l'émission de pascale il est venu
chez moi
je vous dis qu en tout cas pascal même
pas du tout claude et que et que charles
et que charlotte elle n'osait même pas
que j'aime en lice démolissent sur les
réseaux sociaux en interne avec d'autres
candidats claude en permanence donc je
pense que le témoignage de charlotte
toujours respecte infiniment est très
orientée et que vous êtes manipulés
malades
étaient tout de suite je ne suis
manipulé par personne parce qu'elle ne
sait même pas que je suis ici je n'ai
même pas échangé avec oui j'aurais pu
l'appeler parce qu'il est déjà venu
c'est alors c'est comment ma première
fois j'ai justement j'ai voulu aller
comme moi j'avais envie de venir oui et
sans être manipulé par personne et vous
parlez très souvent des choses que vous
ne connaissez pas quand vous voyez un an
par jacques aulong charlotte vois que
vous le connaissez bien
je comprends pas comment on peut dire
des choses qu'on dont on fait un pas
vers les réseaux sociaux vous animez
beaucoup contre claude excusez-moi
autres clubs même pas de lui j'ai parlé
une fois de lui pendant
ma diffusion sur les réseaux vous en
parlait souvent bella zoo n'était forts
du pack alors qu'elle est organisée à
l'envoyer dire ça ressort témoins qu'à
une chose où je parle de de claude
aujourd'hui vers les régions et demi que
je n'ai pas dit quelque chose sur chloé
beaucoup de témoignages d'anciens
candidats
[Applaudissements]
cyril j'allais ballon fait permet donc
j'arrive dans les tout prochains mois tu
as des gars de koh lanta qui n'empêche
et on
irait là non mais dis non mais c'est mon
tour dans koh lanta bien sûr je ne vais
pas donner les noms je respecte mes
sources